valve has teamed up with Taiwanese
smartphone maker HTC and they've
unveiled their virtual reality headset
vibe which uses valves new VR technology
although the announcement comes coupled
with a slightly melodramatic trailer
that looks like the start of a sci-fi
movie before the technology in question
rises up against mankind this one could
be very cool the device has a 1200 x
1800 pixel screen for each eye and a
refresh rate of 90 frames per second
which allegedly eliminates the jitter
that is common with other VR headsets
the vibe also features a gyro sensor
accelerometer and a laser position
sensor that will track the rotation of
your head and if you pair the device
with two steam VR base stations your
movement around the room can also be
tracked the vive headset will come with
a custom controller and the device is
due out this year given that vibe is
powered by valve steam VR the device
will have access to sting games that
utilize we are a bunch of developers
have signed on to make content for the
device including the room developer
fireproof games also signing honor a
studio called alchemy labs who are
developing a game called job simulator
which appears to be like surgeon
simulator with less scalpel and more
foodstuffs but you can see it for
yourself on gamespot let me know down in
the comments if you're keen for valves
entry into VR we'll keep you updated on
this one so stay tuned to gamespot
you